Right,
so let's say you have oriented yourself
but not perfectly because you're full of
mistakes and errors,
so then what do you do because you have
to fix those errors but you still have
to be oriented
and this is why I started getting
interested to get interested in the
phenomenon of meaning as a,
as a phenomenological experience to
experience something as meaningful.
It's not exactly obvious what that means
to experience something as meaningful.
I think that you can,
you can approach it obliquely,
you know,
like if I said watch yourself for two
weeks and notice when you're doing
something that you regard as meaningful,
I could say,
well here,
here's some,
here's some markers.
You lose a sense of time.
You lose a sense of vulnerability,
you're deeply engaged in it.
It seems,
it seems worth the effort,
right?
You forget yourself while you're doing
it.
Maybe you forget your existential
concerns while you're doing it.
You're not ruminating or obsessing about
the meaning of your life.
Right?
So,
so there's markers for,
it's like the flow states that chicks at
my highly described.
Um,
and then you can experience it.
You experienced it under a certain sort
of ritualistic conditions.
You might experience it when you go see
a great movie.
You might experience it when you listen
to music.
I think music is a very,
very standard pathway for people to have
that kind of experience because
virtually everyone gets intimations of
mute of meaning from music and I think
music music is hierarchically structured
patterns that are representative of
being laying itself out properly.
It's something like that,
so it's an abstract representation of
proper being and so we can.
We can grapple with the phenomena of
music and we can.
We can bark or phenomena meaning we can
box it in a little bit and start to
conceptualize it.
We can start to conceptualize it perhaps
as the manifestation of a deep instinct
and so I would say well meaning is what
manifests itself when you are,
when you've oriented yourself properly
and when you've optimized the flow of
information between you.
When you between you and chaos.
That might be the right way of thinking
about it because you think about a piece
of music because you want it to be
predictable,
but you don't want it to be perfectly
predictable.
You want to be it to be predictable with
some interesting variations and
predictable with some variations that
make sense and maybe you can
conceptualize that as something like
this.
It's like it's predictable that this
order of of stability,
but it's varying down here from time to
time and so you've got stable stability
there,
but variability there and you can handle
that so you want
an overarching structure stability with
some internal variability and maybe
that's the way that you update yourself
without falling apart.
And then I would say you can find the
pathway,
the up optimal rate of update by relying
on your sense of meaning.
That's what it's for.
What it tells you is that you're.
You're wandering your way through the
world between the catastrophes of chaos
in the catastrophes of order and now and
then you swing into the proper locale.
You're where you should be and what
happens is you get engaged by that.
You can meaningfully engaged by that and
it's fragile.
It'll move on you,
right?
Because it's very difficult to exist at
that point constantly.
Your bad habits,
all sorts of things.
Your situation.
There's all sorts of things that are
going to interfere with that,
but that doesn't mean that that isn't
where you should be,
and so then you might say,
well,
that's where you should strive to be all
the time,
and then the question might be,
well,
what would it be like if you were there
all the time?
And I think that's where intimations of
paradise come from mean when words think
it was.
Wordsworth talked about intimations of
immortality and childhood.
People tend to romanticize their
childhood because of the sense of
intense engagement that goes along with
being a child and it's one of the
wonderful things about being around
children.
Actually.
It's,
it's,
it's what they pay you for their care
and the way that children pay you for
their care is that they turn normal
things into magic again when you're
around them because you've seen it 100
times before and so when you see it,
you don't see it.
You see what you already know,
but when a child sees that they don't
because they don't know,
they see it and then when you watch them
see it,
you see it too,
and so it's just,
it's tremendous fun leading a small
child around to do things that you've
done before because they're so,
you know,
they're like this.
They're like all the time and you know,
maybe that's too much.
Then they cry and they get upset and all
of that,
but a good part of the time it's just
wild eyed wonder and then you can see
the world through their eyes and it's
payment.
And so that's that sense of being
engaged.
Like that is something that people love
about children and and rightly so,
but it's also a marker to the proper way
of being.
You know,
there,
there's a dictum in the.
This is a union idea that there's no
difference between the archetype of the
wise old man and the archetype of the
child.
They're the same thing because the wise
old man is the person who found what he
had in childhood but lost.
Right?
It's a that's a very powerful moment.
Teeth is that the purpose of maturation
is to return to this state of childhood
as a mature B,
not to stay in the state of childhood,
that's Peter Pan,
but to make the sacrifices necessary for
maturation and then return so well.
How do you do that?
Well,
you do that in part by noting what it is
that's meaningful for you to engage in.
I would say it's your nervous system
reporting to you,
right hemisphere and left hemisphere
balanced.
The balance between chaos and order
produces an output that says you are in
the right place.
It's a perception.
The meaning is a perception of being in
the right place.
It's the genuine thing.
However,
because it can be pathologized.
That's the thing and that's why I think
there is a call to virtue in most great
religious traditions.
If you're going to rely on your sense of
meaning to Orient you,
you have to play a straight game because
otherwise you warp and twist the inputs
and then the mechanism won't function
properly.
You know,
it's like if you.
If you were only,
if you're,
if you blinded yourself to half the
world,
you can't use your perceptions,
Orient yourself properly because the
half of the world that you're ignoring
is going to pop up at you unexpectedly
and take you down,
and so if your relationship with the
world isn't pristine,
honest,
primarily,
then you can't rely on your own internal
orienting mechanisms and then you either
fall into chaos,
which is an absolute catastrophe,
or you have to rely on some kind of
external authority and that makes you
prone to possession by tyrannical
etiologies,
for example.
Which gives you that sense of meaning
that you should in fact have as a
consequence of your own action.